o Olá a todos
eu eu eu
tenho como proposta
daquilo que vou que vou falar eu vou
falar sobre sobre a arte e a liberdade
eu
ouvido o Miguel Rui a e lembrei-me um
pouco um pouco de mim porque
os os livrinhos são também a minha
ferramenta de trabalho e são a minha
ferramenta de liberdade
porque eu acho que a arte falta uma
liberdade que a minha então em primeiro
lugar vamos fazer então uma viagem até o
meu trabalho por aquilo que eu que eu
faço
é
este este trabalho que o do meu nome
pintura feita sobre sobre uma revista é
eu gosto muito de de fazer reciclagem e
muitas vezes somente por razões
económicas às vezes não tenho dinheiro
para comprar material e então aproveito
as revistas e desenho sobre as revistas
e neste caso é é uma revista
o que está colada sobre uma caixa de
eletricidade ou seja sobre uma caixa de
água
e esta também é é uma revista É uma
vista que se chama parque e que eu
também utilizei aqui chama-se aqui há
gato eu gosto muito de gatos geralmente
o desenho muitos gatos
Oi desculpa
este chama-se janela Magazine também é
aproveitamento do revistas é que são
colados
sobre a janelas Esta é uma janela que
está no quebra costas também na Fernando
Tomás
e este me chama se a máquina elétrica de
cores e também a utilização de desenhos
sobre as revistas e sobre caixas de
eletricidade
e este são postais
geralmente são postais que eu que eu vou
buscar ou Tropical Ouçam Fly diz que
utilizo a parte de trás do slime e
desenho sobre eles chama-se nesta rua
mora a música EA Liberdade
e continuando ainda é um desenho feito
sobre uma revista
e diz que talvez estejam a falar a
sempre do senhor das conversas eu acho
que arte é também uma conversa é uma
conversa sempre dinâmica
continuando Este é um trabalho feito
sobre a parte de trás
dos slides geralmente neste tipo de
trabalho
eu uso marcador e pastel
em volta novamente os postais do café
tropicão
Oh e
vamos passar a ilustração então eu digo
algumas vezes costume mostrar os meus
textos gosto de desenhar os cadernos
quando viajo eu faço muito nisso as
viagens me inspiram a imagem que se
segue é a capa do meu livro de poesia
noção das palavras editado pela quase
e este é o livro
Se tiver tempo eu vou dizer o poema a
Andaluzia é um pássaro Andaluzia um
poeta um poeta que escreve com as pedras
e o sol é o velho que vive nessas pedras
é o pássaro que pousa nas árvores de
Andaluzia Andaluzia uma aventura um
silêncio edificado quando as suas
mulheres se vestem de terra Andaluzia
Andaluzia um pássaro Luzia um poeta é um
tanto chora um planta que voa Eu vi um
camponês ladrão do a terra a terra era
uma carta onde ele fará o amor Andaluzia
era o seu amor Andaluzia era a sua terra
e eu que sou estrangeiro e não percebi
aquele amor agora me com ovo e sinto que
Andaluzia O Amor Universal Andaluzia um
pássaro Andaluzia um poeta
e esta foi uma ilustração feita para um
caderno em parceria com o Damião
que faz com os cadernos muito bonitos
que se chama 1/1 então este uma parceria
com o Daniel
esta foi uma colaboração com a companhia
marionete a peça tomada de consciência
penso 2004
e este também mais um dos meus
cabelinhos que eu gosto de usar a então
é era a minha representação ou a maneira
como eu vejo o corpo mal peso e o
estábulo estar no filme O Grande ditador
continuando a novamente a utilização ou
a reutilização de prestar-lhes o
oceano e a casa da música
Eu Gosto muito está muito a ver com a
liberdade gosto muito de pintar sobre os
muros
é este mundo fica situado na Rua Direita
onde há um jardim comunitário
então uma história mas devido ao nosso
ao tempo não vou falar sobre isso
e novamente a reutilização de materiais
continuando na reutilização
Este é também um trabalho feito nesse
jardim comunitário a abri a janela e a
poesia voa
Eu não sou propriamente
Talvez um um desenhador A por silêncio
mas eu acho que estou a um mais um poeta
que desenha do que um um desenhador em
si
eu não tenho mais uma abordagem poética
do desenho é isso é novamente
uma intervenção nesse mesmo espaço
chama-se o Comboio não vai passar por
aqui
é porque este local era onde
eventualmente iria passar o metro
mondego
e esta é uma é uma caneca que foi uma
parceria quando na c*** Fortunato chama
de dentes bem afiados
a versão a utilização de cartola seja de
tubos do cartão que eu vou pedir aos
Comerciantes e depois Pinto
sobre ele fica um um efeito bastante
interessante e até musical que já tem
havido muitas pessoas que utilizam para
fins musicais estes mesmos clubes então
um caderno e mostrar é um grande aluno
está ou não ainda não sei não precisaria
dar ficar muitos que eu que eu fui
vendendo
e este é uma loja na cidade do Porto a
uma 20 é uma vintage e é também um mural
isto é uma exposição na biblioteca de
penela e este é um livro é a capa de um
livro sobre o Fado de Coimbra
terminando a esta minha apresentação
desculpa eu que eu vou tirar os meus
óculos que que é para o lobo ver melhor
E aí
e
eu e o que eu escrevi tem um pouco a ver
com aquilo que eu penso do que deve ser
a arte EA Liberdade
arte e a liberdade a liberdade que
Embora tenha uma relação com o fazer tem
um caminho que tem a ver com a
consciência essa que leva ao
conhecimento e daí a construção de um
universo pessoal onde a aprendizagem se
deve ser entrar no desenvolvimento e
sentido crítico não devemos ser só uma
assimilação de conceitos ou uma
aceitação de modelos mas tem de fomentar
a discussão e convidaram uma leitura
própria arte reflete o que somos EA
sociedade em que estamos inseridos mas
não é a sociedade que deve tomar conta
de nós criar ou decidir o nosso gosto
arte serve para nos iluminar não serve
para alimentar interesses sejam eles de
natureza política econômica outros a uma
relação não tendo é uma dependência
aprendizagem da matéria arte deve ter o
choque capaz de romper o círculo E
permitir saídas não pode fechar nem
limitar a procura tenho de pôr em causa
a diferença entre o pensamento
conservador e as vanguardas é que as
vanguardas incomodam respeitam a
individualidade
fomentam a mudança o crescimento são
dinamizadoras da transformação de
mentalidades
muitas vezes aprisionados muitas vezes
sujeitas ao domínio administrativo da
máquina quiser sobre a obra e favor
digita a sugestão ao medo EA
desvalorização do seu trabalho e da sua
pessoa fazer a linha divisória entre o
que arte pobre e o que arte rica o
respeito não pode aditar com o
preconceito o preconceito É também um
limite à liberdade podemos ter as nossas
opções estéticas mas não devemos ser
polícias numa sociedade livre que é
também o deve ser também uma sociedade
direitos arte tem de carne o que digam
Qual é a estrada Precisamos do teatro
precisamos da música das artes plásticas
da dança mas não precisamos de ditaduras
ou ditadores arte tem que ser também o
combate à pressão do grupo sobre mim
devido construir um Marco livre permitir
o acesso EA divulgação da obra de arte
restrições ou que qualquer tipo de
censura uma arte livre é uma arte
consciente é uma arte que serve
verdadeiramente a comunicação
e eu terminei a minha apresentação a
estava um bocado difícil porque eu eu
tenho um sentimento do palco eu confesso
que tenha EA mais fácil de fazer no que
às vezes comunicar aqui o que se faz e
queria agradecer ao Frederico e a Ana
queria também agradecer a todos vós
também os participantes que estiveram
aqui antes porque acho que me inspiraram
muito perder por Miguel Ruivo inspirou
me porque quando eu te fazer um desenho
do melhor Ruivo aqui e então muito
obrigado a vocês